but i was just like asking like how
someone or
like as a man would feel like if your
wife is inevitably making a lot more
money than you are
you want to talk about that i don't mind
you yeah
because i feel like that would like make
like if you're making a lot of money in
your life he's making a lot of money too
then like
here's the problem that works out here's
the real reason why
most folks listen i probably wouldn't
like it yeah
if you gotta work that much and make
that much money that means you're not
gonna be there
to raise the kids right and at the end
of the day me i really enjoy working i'm
really focused on what i do
i understand she makes more and i
respect that do your thing but you know
if you want a wife who's gonna be at
home with the kids one of the parents
has to spend a lot of time there
someone's gonna have to be on the back
burner when it comes to her i'd prefer
to be my wife so that's the only reason
why i wouldn't like it
if you can work two hours and make a
billion dollars and [ __ ]
your thing i got no problem with that
but for me personally i would like
somebody to be at home with the kids
when i'm not able to be there
what did you think about that whole
concept what if your wife makes a lot of
money
more than you and she wants to support
everything like would you be okay with
that and some people like no
other folks that's where that's where i
was heading yeah that's where i was
heading right
i still gotta pull my card out of the
game
right because i was working customer
service she was working for
for this this place for a long time so
she advanced and
and she was she was making a lot
sometimes three
three times whatever sometimes four
times what i was making
but then so if she's making four times
what i make what i'm making
and my schedule is more
malleable than something's gotta give
right i'm gonna i'm gonna be i'm gonna
be there i gotta i gotta do some i gotta
i gotta put my i gotta pull my card out
of the game you know what i mean i'm not
gonna be like
all bitter and stuff and be like oh you
know what i ain't going like i can't
believe she's no
do you shine on do your thing do make
money my money
but if you're going to make more money
i'm going to do something right you know
no
if the brakes if the brakes on your car
is due yes i'll change them i'll change
them i'll i i will
and i have i will change the breaks on
your car
yes i will learn that trade right and
it's going to be money you're not going
to have to spend and you're going to
spend on some other stuff
this is where things went a little bit
off the rail okay and then earn more
money
do typically do not want to date a guy
that makes less money than them
okay but you also cannot rule out
the many exceptions which i could say
exceptions don't make the rule though
they don't make the rules exactly
they don't make the rule but we could
say that it's a good 30
we can't say that all of them are we
talking about the united states are we
talking about the whole world we're
talking about the united states
this is where y'all make mad money right
and ladies are killing it and that's
wonderful but it also ruins their dating
prospects because at the very least
it does 100 and this is not my opinion
these are statistical effects the
numbers say that women who are
far out earning the general men have
harder times because they hate the idea
of dating down
it's not my opinion their studies on
this so when i say this stuff the reason
why they're struggling
is because they make all this money now
right and now they're part of the one
percent
fantastic well the men who are part of
the one percent they don't need to meet
a woman who makes as much as them
that's right they can pull from a girl
who works at mcdonald's a little girl
who
has a trash can and the girl who works
at cbs right they don't care
whereas the women who are making all
that money their pool is smaller
because they're going for guys who work
in corporate offices who make as much as
them
so of course they're going to struggle
okay i wanted to ask a question because
i think that we're going on
runabouts um when it comes to
men now we were asking the questions
before
what do men look in went for in women
when they asked a question when they
want to build
a family thing here's the thing the
reason why i'm saying there's a
disconnect here
is because women think that as they make
more money it's going to be easier for
them to meet people at their level
just listen okay at their level or above
the reason why i brought up the men who
make anything is because when we're
looking at mates we're not looking at
their career choices necessarily
or the financial income that they make
we're looking at a whole bunch of other
factors whether it be
the ability to be cooperative with the
idea of like when they're coming into a
marriage are they thinking about
responsibility
and labor are they thinking about those
ideas are they going to be someone who's
going to be emotionally supportive
so when we're talking about these things
that has nothing to do with your college
degree
or how much money you make and so the
issue that we've had this whole evening
is that people are like well i make this
amount of money it should help me out my
dating prospects but you haven't taken
the time to understand
that men want women for different
reasons so all that extra money all it
did
was price out a bunch of guys you could
have dated otherwise what if she has
everything you want
and the money perfect perfect so so this
is this is where the artists are there
you can't look at things as a black and
white thing if you make it that far as a
woman
climbing the corporate lag ladder
oftentimes it means you have to do
things that
regular women won't you're going to have
to be less agreeable you're going to
have to be
much more stern so already there the
personality traits that men are
generally going to be looking for are
going to be less likely in people
who have to be hyper successful you know
guys who are hyper successful
they're not agreeable they're not
they're not agreeable there are many
things but agreeable's not one of them
and so all the qualities that women have
to emulate in order to be successful
are going to be more traditionally
masculine because those environments are
cut throat
that's one what do you think about that
point what do you mean the part where
you're preaching
preach on go on hey i know hyper
successful women hyper successful women
they gotta move different bro
you want me to repeat what you said what
are you doing i don't get it okay all
right
two i guess if i met a woman and she was
very
feminine and she made as much money and
all this other stuff fantastic but as a
wife
she's gonna have to work a lot so she
can't be home to handle the kids not
necessarily
no because a lot of women leave things
for
motherhood you know you need to be with
that a kid is super needy
and without the mother is not going to
survive you have to breastfeed okay okay
okay okay so
she has to quit her job so all of a
sudden money doesn't matter anymore i
don't want bro why we brought that up
but anyways
so she quits her job and now she's just
a regular woman well all that time that
she's been putting in at work those
extra hours to bust her ass off but she
wasn't on the daily market nearly as
much as women who had more flexible jobs
and who work less hours so she has less
opportunity to meet people
by every metric possible the more money
you make as a woman the harder your
dating prospects are gonna
be and again you guys are fighting me on
this it's cool but understand it's not
my opinion it's the reality
of those women what if she has a course
that's making her two hundred thousand
dollars and that course is evergreen
running on its own and she's
has
i love dungeons and dragons i love
fantasy so we can talk fantasy if you
want
it's not changing i understand if i my
pool of women is anybody who makes
anything
okay so that's a hundred women they make
any i don't care i don't care how much
money they make okay
there's gonna be two of them who make a
hundred thousand i'll beat any of these
women
okay now you line up a hundred men on
the other side okay
there's only two of them that make a
hundred thousand dollars you understand
but they women will only date two of
those guys i as a man
have a hundred women to pick from those
two women
only have two men to pick from and those
two guys are looking at all the other
women and all those women are looking at
them because they make the most do you
not understand how mathematically
it's not in your favor do you understand
that i feel like we deviated from the
question
and i just have to check out after that
because this is what i mean when we're
not having a conversation
and i'm open if you think i'm wrong you
can bring it up but you know for ladies
who are hyper successful it is harder
out there they talk about it all the
time
you know so it just confused me sitting
across from these ladies because
you put numbers in front of their face
you put logic you walk them through
the steps you take them to the door and
you like
open it and these girls will jump in
they'll jump in the bushes and hide and
i'm just like yeah but you already know
you already know that when someone has
already a point
yeah very few people if you bring
facts very few people are mature enough
that whenever they have something that
they think a point that they think
that you bring facts logic yeah
numbers it's not very likely that
they're going to change
their way of thinking that's not the
reality of things
you know whatever they have said their
things set in stone
writer call you they'd rather call you a
misogynistic pig
yup someone that does not you don't
understand
even if you have facts numbers
statistics
yep all all of that
they rather no it's you the problem you
don't understand
instead of just like okay let me just
listen to that it's very conflicting
because it's conflicting
it's conflicting to know that what
you've been thinking
is not true it's very conflicting it has
nothing to do with this subject but i
remember one day
there was one of my friends and it was
something that happened it's a style of
dance that only happened in this
province of quebec and it's a bad
translation of a lot of things
and i remember when i was a kid there
was dance uh
dance classes and dance schools and they
were offering a cl a class
called funky what it was
it was white washed jazz
and white washed by lay in contemporary
and then
it's already white but it was washed it
was washed it was not the technique and
stuff like that
right right right yes they named it
funky i had this friend that did this
style
that did that style for a number of
years and i
showed it to her the facts no funky
means something else
funky is from this funky funk funk
is from that and that and that that
style is something that is purely
invented from out of nowhere it's this
that that would have been able to she
could
she could not accept that she was lied
to or she was wrong
all that time right right it's very it's
very conflicting so for these women
that have been that's been fed that ah
you shouldn't settle you shouldn't sell
you shouldn't settle now they're right
now they're
they're being fed with numbers
statistics yeah
logic and all that and they cannot
understand it
so they bring what well what if what if
something that we don't give a [ __ ]
about and has nothing to do with the
conversation
just to bail them out of having
to being conflicted yeah you know it's
kind of part of the human
experience to overestimate your own
abilities
right that's how humans achieve great
things like
how good they think they're going to be
far outweighs
any logical reason to believe in that
potential that's just
part of the human experience everyone
thinks they're going to be far and it
leads to great things
but if you don't have a little bit of
pragmatism if you always live
life thinking you're the exception
you're living a life of luxury
and i say this because when you come
from dangerous places
you can't walk around saying i'm going
to walk around with bling
because i'm the exception you understand
that there's very real consequences
when you turn out to be the norm and you
get murdered so i think
when i hear people talk like this i'm
like you recognize
it's a luxury it's a privilege to think
like this it's okay maybe you have that
privilege maybe you're exceptional
but you understand if you tell this to
everyone somebody has to die
somebody has to die
for you to live
right when you say
everyone's going to be rich do you
understand
that that means that nobody's going to
be rich or
that some people are going to have to
live poor for you to be different
because by very simple numbers not
everyone can be rich
rich is an idea that you will have
ampleness you have
more you have excess that you have
abundance
for you to have abundance there has to
be somebody who has less
right and let's be honest only a few of
us can have abundance
it's why they're called the one percent
so when people are fed this dream that
they're all going to be astronauts
firefighters and
super soldiers and special forces no
there are special forces and there are
prizes there's privates
okay so this is where it comes down
where people have to stop living in
these delusions
now as far as this conversation goes
it's just hard
to everybody likes a underdog
not everybody there's going to be a
loser to have
one underdog there has to be
losers and the vast majority of people
are going to be losers everybody that
goes
into the olympics wants to be number one
there are about 168 countries up in this
[ __ ]
and even more 212 i don't know what
happened
something like that 200 something plus
countries up in this [ __ ]
there's only three medals and here's
what i'm gonna say and here's what i'm
saying
okay our media has done a great job of
painting every underdog story as a
success
when the reality is there's 30 other
underdogs who are in that exact same
tournament
and they all lost but you only follow
the story of the one who wins
right this is the american dream but you
can go way beyond if you really try
most people are not rocky too most
people are watching one
yeah and they stay one yeah for the rest
of the sequels
that's right so it's important to know
that and
when i hear this stuff look i'm not here
to say ladies who are successful deserve
this or it's good what i'm saying is
ladies once you've taken up the space
that men have traditionally taken which
is the high earner
by definition you're going to limit your
options that's why men have dated
anywhere they
can they don't do that same stuff they
don't go like a has to be
we've always when we've occupied we date
anybody
but now y'all want that and you still
want to live under that same traditional
gender role
well of course it's going to limit your
options it's basic math if men
came out and all of them said i need a
nine out of ten
you know what would happen a lot of them
would die alone
yeah definitely and you wouldn't feel
bad for them one know why
because it's not sensible for a hundred
men to be lined up with a hundred women
and they all go for a nine out of ten
by numbers there's only going to be a
few women out there who are top tier
model like victoria's secret people
you know what's gonna so that's why i'm
just saying that go ahead
and you know what actually go ahead men
have been dating all over the place
right and yet still are
dying alone so what makes you think
that you're gonna limit your pool and
everybody's gonna happy happy
make it make sense make it make sense
doesn't make any sense bro
actually dating and lowering our
standards
and settling and yet there's still
people left and right and center time
alone
i'm talking about men talking about men
yeah but they're still men dying alone
yes exactly my point and
what makes you think that all of y'all
all of you around this table are gonna
have all these standards that make no
goddamn sense
that are restraining your pool and all
that y'all gonna have no you're gonna ha
you're gonna die alone a lot of you
especially like that
come on make it that's it doesn't make
sense i was never good at mathematics
that oh that i get that one i understand
it doesn't make any sense but yeah i
agree with you bro i agree with you you
already know i'm already on board so
let's get it yeah these are my thoughts
let us know what you guys think or these
ladies delusional or was i the one who's
wrong i don't know
american women are different
y'all different i don't know what y'all
smoking but y'all different
and y'all need to learn your maths i
need to learn your basic nets
okay when we talk about america we talk
about canada too because we're part of
the american
continent yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
you